une structure pour accompagner les
familles lors d'une séparation
c'est le principe directives de l'
agence de recouvrement des impayés des
pensions alimentaires
appelé aussi harry pas un dispositif
instauré par la loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale de 2010 est depuis le
1er janvier
on considère que 30 à 40 % des pensions
alimentaires ne sont pas versées aux
parents qui devrait la toucher et bien
entendu 85 % des familles monoparentales
étant des femmes
je considère que le non paiement des
pensions alimentaires est une violence
économique faite aux femmes en france
une famille sur cinq serait
monoparentales avec ce dispositif les
impayés seront couverts par la caf
jusqu'à 24 mois de pension alimentaire
au lieu de 6 grâce notamment à une
allocation de soutien familial larripa
regroupe une soixantaine d'employés 45
d'entre eux sont des travailleurs
sociaux
ils accompagneront les familles dans
leurs différentes démarches nous mettons
en oeuvre une allocation qui permet en
fait pendant un certain temps jusqu'à ce
que la pension alimentaire soit fixée
par le juge d'apporter un soutien
financier à ces familles et de les aider
après dans les démarches de fixation des
pensions alimentaires
ça fait plus d'un an que la branche
famille travaille sur la mise en place
cette agence dans les délais et en
particulier avec ce site qui a été
lancée ce matin à partir du 1er avril
2018 larripa aura une nouvelle
prérogative rendre obligatoire
l'application de l'accord à l'amiable
lors de séparations de couples pacsés ou
en concubinage